think this is a plot by the iranian  government  against a former official of the u.s  government i can say i can't say a lot  of things but i can say i'm not the only  one that  that the ayatollahs in tehran are trying  to assassinate so this is the kind of  government we have in in iran and i  think it should tell everybody including  the government of great britain why this  is a government that trying to  resuscitate the 2015 nuclear deal is a  is a terrible mistake strategically  for us and for our friends in the middle  east i've been granted secret service  protection again by president biden  since last december i think  obviously that was the correct decision  i'm grateful that he made that decision  and it will continue  as long as they deem it necessary it's  not my call